c'est un mec sont là que tout a commencé
quelque part hollande
comme ça
et
mais
ça fait le reste
en avant la rue
pour les gens qui connaissent un peu les
ce qu'on appelle les musiques issues de
d'autres contrées que que l'occident il
ya un mot qui est apparu dans l'est
grosso modo au milieu des années 80 qui
s'appelait world music en anglais qui
veut dire en français le gip du monde et
cette notion de musique du monde est
apparu aussi parce que il y avait de
plus en plus de musiciens africains
donc c'est la musique africains qui en
fait suggérer ou amener ce mot-là cette
expression là de world music musique du
monde
amanda ware
commun
non
là où elle est
il
c'est à dire à l'épaule zali 80 on se
rappelle bien les gens qui étaient
connus pour un certain public européen
blanc s'appelait salif keita sa plume
pour un petit peu mal et du bon goût
mais qui étaient là avant et on a oublié
qu'avant l'apparition des mots world
music
il y avait déjà des musiciens africains
en europe en occident france notamment
et par mieux et vient certes un bon gars
qui vient de l'angola qui étaient là qui
est l'ancien coureur athlétisme qui a
été un champion du portugal qui doit
donc la boxe et l'angola est évoquée
colonie portugaise qui passait par
portugal est arrivé ici et chanter
moi la mort
c'est
pour nous
en amont abonnés
que ce soit vrai
non
la veste ils trient un peu de sang des
belle ballade triste et des musiques un
peu chaloupés un peu dansante qui
inconsciemment pour le public occidental
rappellent vaguement le brésil bon on
oublie ont bien sûr que c'est le brésil
qui a irrité quand même des traditions
et des rythmes angolais
c'était l'occasion d'un voyage en
hollande en 1974
enfin 73 que dans une société une petite
société hollandaise qui s'appelait
munich fréquence à utrecht
j'étais pas du dgt pas du tout là pour
ça et il m'avait donné un 33 tours d'une
marque il s'appelait monras bessat et
mondes année se disent que j'ai écouté
en venant à paris j'ai eu un choc
extraordinaire et s'agisse effectivement
dû l'angola 72 le premier disque de
conteur
voilà
elle
ben laden
le compte en banque que c'était 1972
c'est quand un bon guinéen à belgique à
louvain il a nous avez d'étudiants
quitté la série en étudiant qui étaient
toutes à oreille et bang il fait
remonter avec le studio un cap verdien
et alors lui qui nous avons déjà fait
enregistrer sur avec eux une bertone et
obertan qui me dit que qui ne parlait
des banques alors faire une contre
attaque ben oui je le vois qu'il était
un bon artiste un artiste même
culturelle parce que ça c'était mon
attention des fêtes chose culturelle
pour démontrer ici à l'europe
notre contenu
je suis arrivé à paris avec n'orchestre
ville et le brésil j'ai travaillé dans
un cabaret après j'ai quitté c'est
cabaye travers qu'un groupe g la musique
afro brésilienne surtout la musique en
gaule angolaise et brésilienne
à ce moment là j'ai trouvé avec deux
autres musiciens
une formation qui représentait vraiment
cette culture là que negro brésilienne
en fait
et puis on est allé chercher un bon gars
bas beaucoup celle et l époque là bas
devenir parent s'installer travailler
avec nous proposer à vendre a fait un
duo s'appelle clients c'est moi d'y
ancrer bon là on a fait ce tour en 74
573 180 à ce moment là on est parti pour
enregistrer le disque s'appelle à la 74e
avaient déjà le fasse à 12 qui était
sorti avant les 74 répartiront les amis
c'est adam fait ce disque marabese le
premier maison de disques a fait et on a
formé cette yourte
on va faire la musique d' angola brésil
surtout envolée bahia parce que c'est
plus proche c'est la culture les petits
proches hongroise il sait bahia et
angola on est réuni on a fait ses
premiers disques on est bien préparé
pour travailler dans un cabaret qui t'a
bien connu qui s'appelait disco phase l
époque c'est ici
bon d'accord on a passé des années
m
à
je suis un enfant de la grosse ici n'est
équipé que c'est le bon goût c'est un
endroit 50 km 60 km de la capitale nord
et celles à auditionner
mais toute façon j'ai toujours cru à
luanda donc la capitale même n'est ce
pas la grosse majorité des anglais de
ceux nés dans les bidonvilles sont tous
nés dans les favelas ce n'est dans les
musiques chez nous et donc c'est là nous
sommes grandi avec une bonne belle
dignité parce que les parents n'étaient
pas complètement déboussolé quoi c'était
des gens bien coût du travail est visé
ce boulot on était très jeune et on
faisait des choses que qui était à voir
avec nous qui nous disait respect c'est
à dire que des choses à l'eau alors des
choses nous c'était quoi c'était déjà la
culture la culture il fallait la
pratique et parce qu'on était interdit
par les colons de développer et on
n'avait pas de matériel nous
construisons nous mêmes ne propres
instruments 7 et fantastique n'est ce
pas une façon de résister et alors parce
qu'on n'avait pas d'argent on allait
dans le magasin et acheter des guitares
piano ou cédera pas question
heureusement d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya
des mâles qui vient pour bien c'est à
dire qu'avec cette résistance qui nous
avons pu avoir
on a construit non même instrument avec
des barils avec la peau là dessus et
c'est avec la d15 des instruments
typiques
nous ne construisons nous mêmes nos
instruments c'était bon c'était une très
bonne époque il s'en donne une allure d
sérieux n'était pas conditionné voulais
c'était beau avec l'harmonica
ça se passait comme ça reste normalement
dans les quartiers pauvres de chez moi
dans le bidonville n'est ce pas toujours
pas ce que c'est
paris 15 6 a non seulement pris josy
beaucoup la guitare originaire de
l'angola henry pourrait d'ailleurs le
semba qu'on joue là bas s'il ya pas de
il n'ya pas ans m costaud ça c'est
choquant qu'on appelle des bras
art
non
en deuxième temps 3 tueur je l'avais
appelé rises portugais signifie racines
ça dit bien ce que ça veut dire qu'on
voit les racines qui pousse d'un côté et
qui fait un trou sûreté a traversé
l'atlantique il va au brésil qui sortent
là bas il ya surtout dans ses disques et
trois choses très important kanaan à la
guinée la guinée conakry
prenez à l'angola yona bahia parce qu'on
a la guinée conakry les jours maka qui
c'étaient les grands saxophonistes
arrange retrouvailles avec nous donc
dans ce disque là il ya ce triangle
c'était vraiment ces gens là qui sont
parties de l'afrique pour aller au
brésil s'était guinée le john togo un
peu plus bas après la voilà surtout la
bonne à bord c'est pour ça que ses
disques l'appeler racines de l'angola au
brésil
e
c'est peut-être aussi cette influence
portugaise sur la musique angolaise
c'est à dire ce mélange de cultures que
nous avons su aussi sur l'afrique
anglophone et afrique francophone et qui
je trouve est particulièrement sensible
sur le sur l'afrique les ophones pour
moi c'est un des meilleurs disques on a
fait musicalement parlant tout
tous les autres sont beaux mais celui là
pour moi c'était bien parce que non
seulement parce qu'ils essaient c'est
bien rangé ses bienfaits non parce que
ce sont les titres du disque ça veut
dire book des choses dans ces 10 cas
même chanson créole et j'avais composé
gros match entre rolle il s'appelle
remake du connaît jeannot pendant quatre
mois
parcours a dit non lui même des civils
tan tan tan tan digne d'aval et c'était
à l'époque qui aussi y avait cette bière
dépendance de piéger ses dépendances de
ville est cabré
c'est justement à cette époque ont
collaboré avec ses jardins et c'est pour
ça et chinois qui dansaient disent qu'il
ya un morceau un créole
il ya un autre point le rôle du bon gras
aussi les pales du chante mais pendant
ce toutes sources surtout cette période
il y avait toujours la guerre la guerre
d'indépendance à mango la bomba étant
quelqu'un de la ville de luanda dans la
capitale tenu par le parti qui est
actuellement au pouvoir qui s'appelle
ump à la dent qu'il était plutôt engager
un pea là vers les trois quarts des
artistes modernes angolais sont tous
plus ou moins sous la coupe la main
afideo un pea là parce qu'ils sont en
vie les six ans parce qu'il y en a très
peu qui sont plutôt unità qui tutoie à
l'est du pays à la compagnie où c'est un
peu plus difficile comme de chanter
d'aborder de faire des concerts inédits
monologuant bob gainey
12 lors des 6 g en double dames en voilà
un bon gars étaient engagés un petit peu
du côté npa là comme beaucoup d'autres
et puis un jour
change d'avis et il va sur ce du l'unita
les ennemis irréductibles du lpa là et
ici il faut dire qu'en france quand même
l'opinion publique plutôt de gauche qui
suivait su musique étiez plutôt un pea
là parce que l'unita est ont vu le con
mi temps le parti soutenu à l'époque à
la du sud est un raciste par les démons
grosso modo le 3 mai des américains ou
de pro-américain le grand capitalisme
méchant tout ça est un pea là plutôt
soutenu à l'époque un fond de guerre
froide l'urss et le conte d'été du ps
dans les jambes de gauche comme les gens
de gauche étaient les plus ardents
supporters des musiques africaines et
ils ont peut-être vu que ça comme une
trahison
voilà voilà
étant donné que j'ai commencé avec la
politique c'est à dire le disque se
nommait roule à 72,7 en disques
essentiellement politique
alors il faut la continuer il fallait
être cohérent avec moi même par rapport
à mes compatriotes à la voilà le fact
d'être ici à l'extérieur c'est à des
paris lisbonne et d'autres pays enfants
savaient pas dire que je dois me
détacher d'espagne mais son origine et
surtout la politique c'est elle définit
tout le reste
alors bien sûr il ya des chansons qui
font partie de cette prise de position
logique normale
zelaya
deux grosses forces politiques qui se
battent encore le real a grimpé à
l'accueil au pouvoir et l'unita qui est
entre guillemets dans l'opposition bonds
est certain et dominent les régions de
diamants et d'autres les 2000 les
régions le pétrole et c'est ça un peu
qui entretient cette guerre parce que
ces richesses la servent à acheter les
armes et tout ça il faut pas alors il
faut le rappeler
et ça continue entretenir cette guerre
allait me défonce dit il ya pas plus
grand malheur que des richesses
jean tabary
shota galinée c'est à dire qu'il faut
bannir la poule dans le poulailler où le
coq common pas revoir son charme par
rapport à son attitude vis-à-vis en
orient n'est ce pas
les gens ce qu'ils font vraiment de
thème de bong parce que de départ et
j'ai pas l'intention de dire par exemple
que le coq se limite à et la poule si
l'ump n'y a pas du tout ça fonctionne
pas comme ça les compositions
artistiques mais c'est le peuple
après parce que ce n'est pas plus que
celui des conséquences de la politique
et ce paquet dans le terrain même et à
l'heure à chaque fois qu'il ya un
message eux mêmes qui vont donner
l'ampleur enfin qu'ils veulent rapport
au texte
moi à voir avec mes parents parce que
les parents à l'afrique il était déjà
comme ça sans être maxis léninisme et
communistes rien du tout quelqu'un qui
tue agit bien et va partager avec
d'autres
quelqu'un qui a dû silva mais rien ne va
changer avec la farine
donc il ya toujours comme ça des
échanges et des cadeaux aussi qu'on fait
en venant ici en europe
bon il y avait beaucoup de problèmes les
situations terriblement comme chantôme
de mandali chanter ce que je pouvais
apporter par 0 manifestations pro model
c'était avec mon spectacle
au moment où il fallait faire je les
fais je le fais avec
j'en ai ça je le fais avec samora machel
d'ailleurs je suis allé au moins cinq
mille fois j'ai même fait une chanson
dommages à sa machine
d'ailleurs c'est pas par hasard qu'on a
tous oui ça il faut le dire c'est pas
par hasard ils ces choses continuent
comme ça et aujourd'hui moi ça
m'enchante pas avoir un pays énorme
comme l'angola avec cette pauvre et et
du braille
il cite aussi grave que nous subissons
tous n'est ce pas mais la solidarité est
toujours là parce qu'il ya toujours des
événements il nous participons c'est
normal
jodar ali sauta galles il paraît qu'on
est rentré dans une grenade qui sert un
peu l'ancien colon la sienne que l'on
sait le présent colons d'aujourd'hui ce
qui nous veut un peu comme ça dans cet
état d'esprit et c'était à d'esprit
complètement déboussolé et la jeunesse
et des conseils malheureusement parce
qu'elle s'intéresse pas vraiment à la
cause d'un malaise la cause africaine
et quand on dit qu'on donne
l'opportunité aux noirs qu'est ce que ça
veut dire donner opportunités il faut
que les gens s'expriment par rapport à
sa connaissance parce qu à pas mal de
noir ont fait des études ne sont pas
dans l'assemblée de la république
portugaise ils ne sont pas dans le
gouvernement du portugal
ils sont pas dans les partis politiques
portugais et on se demande pourquoi à
cause de la couleur de la peau tout
simplement je trouve que qu'un peu plus
du monde peut nous imposer encore un
colonialisme quelconque
l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est qu'on se
regarde dans les yeux qu'on soit plus
clairement enfoncés que l'autre s'est
pas passé par le problème d'aujourd'hui
celle en 2000 qu'est la diva est alors
en fonction de ça il faut qu'on se
retrouve vraiment et on se demande qui
nous sommes
où est ce qu'on va la mondialisation
c'est quoi c'est encore la colonisation
c'est relou de néo colonialisme c'est
encore le concert de notre pauvreté va
pour nous pour nous écraser
et ça c'est dommage parce que certains
africains font le jeu
j'aime quand on a beau
des gma
ap
oh
j'ai lahieyte demandant là ouais
je l'avais
ouais
aulas laisse pas sa femme sa part
c'est à michel mallard
pokémon
toi qui fais là comme en avoir
j'ai pas
non
il
voilà
oui
ouah
moi
chacun notamment monté
m
alona mon mât
bah moi
à
ce qui m'intéresse c'est un bon gars
c'est sa voix c'est la nostalgie qui la
danse à voir c'est l'ambiance qui a
autour de lui de sa musique
et c'est ça que je vais défendre donc
bon bah il a la charge pour moi de
parler dans une langue que j'adore
musicalement c'est à dire le portugais
revue par l'africa et sonorités à nulle
autre quoi et puis quand il a juste et
bon gars c'est d'abord une voix une voix
particulière voix éraillée une voix
chaleureuse
je parle en tant en termes artistiques
quoi vaganay m'agace rêve
mais kisangani quito
eyeos m'engage l'adopter touché parce qu
alger mais j'adore les chanteuses et
fréquente pas les dati vient de faire le
petit cap mesure les choristes ali
quelqu'un qui peut défendre une chanson
début à la fin et lui donner la chaleur
et une existence la voix est
extraordinaire et le feeling est
fabuleux il a un sens de la puis un très
grand sens de la mélodie
c'est un tout je dire on dit c'est pas
un artiste je savais ça parce que ça
passe pas
moi je connais bien les la tonalité les
tendres et les la façon à quel bon
gâteau je chantais parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres guitaristes d'autres
anciens des armes je ne connais pas je
le connais parce que je vécu sept ans et
demi j'ai senti qu'ils avaient besoin de
quelque chose qui allait avec certains
types de 2010 des harmonies des
arrangements qui allait avec cette voie
ce n'est pas le cas d'autres gens qui
étaient tous à l'exploiter d'une autre
façon
moi simplement j'étais l'harmonie de
l'enjeu à l'époque cette loi du manga
pita de moi je restais paris bonvin
partie portugal c'est là que pour gaza
salut pour cela lui mais ça n'a pas
empêché qu'on continue de faire la même
province un gardien d'hamouma d'éléments
galibert l'année
à sitra use hiver j'adore
iweb nouveau job
elles naissent déjà les mâles aux gars
et au chaman
denia j'aime beaucoup je sais pas
et au fond
car si bas
à 10 h flotat n'évolue pas dieu
aj mandat court jusqu'à jouer
maj en 1968 69 kg bat tous les records
du portugal du 400 m c'était athènes
au moment où le championnat d'europe
d'athlétisme et moi bien sûr
représentant le portugal devra voler
bien sûr l'époque oblige eternity
colonisés par eux et voilà les
spécialités c'était celle-là même si
quelquefois je faisais quand même les
200 m aussi il y avait des jeux parce
que pour tout cas normalement il faisait
de nous au brésil est décrit dans cette
compétition il venait du brésil passé
pour mandat pour rechercher de toute
façon c'est toujours dans cette optique
la recherche et les la matière première
est humain n'est ce pas physique tout ça
il sait faire c'est 80 que ce soient les
revenus
il ya un journaliste est allé là bas et
qui m'a vu qu'il y appartenir benfica
quand il a vu ça et il faut absolument
qu'il y participe pour la métropole de
l'époque c'était lisbonne et qu'ils
fassent l'athlétisme et voilà le défi
que nous courions levier me suis
démarqué ici pas avec les sommes que le
footballeur bien sûr parce qu'elle est
beaucoup plus d'argent et pas le cas
nous met toute façon c'est comme ça que
tout a démarré il y en arrivant ici
bien sûr j'ai fait la politique mon
amour ma manière
72 j'étais obligé de sortir du portugal
pour des raisons politiques et allées à
hollande
voilà s'est produit quelque chose de
très important dans ma vie étant donné
que j'étais quand même lié à cette un
mouvement de libération en afrique dans
ma conscience politique et alors quand
on est comme ça dans une situation
pareille réfugié politique et c'est
alors un peu plus courir c'est fini et
il a cédé 21,72 même si j'avais encore
la force continue n'est ce pas
physiquement était bon mais
psychiquement pas du tout parce qu'il y
avait d'autres raisons
et en plus le pays avait changé j'étais
hollande à ce moment là c'était plus le
portugal la famille les amis et c'est
fini
il y avait la police politique
portugaise quand même que vous courez
après c'était un peu partout donc quand
ils ont vu que moi ce moment je me suis
baptisée de bons gars voilà c'était
important cette question ces replis de
bons gars n'est ce pas mais ils ont
quand même découvert ce bon gars a était
le barcelo de cavale champion du
portugal 400 m ce moment là j'étais un
peu recherché par tous et c'est normal
que ça se fasse c'est obligé de fuir ses
mémoires notre pays et même si ce
moment-là y avait une option
c'était l'option musicale parce que la
nostalgie n'est ce pas de mon envol à
cher et aussi du portugal
quelque sorte vous que je chante il tue
le week-end avec les marocains verdien
m
mon nom
en avant
l'angola s'est fait l'un des pays qui
mais a quand même resté à travers la
gorge parce que quand j'y étais c'est un
pays fort mais là c'est le ont tué à
luanda c'est une ville extraordinaire
très très belle et quand tu voit
l'ambiance qui a lancé la tuer ça te
serre la gorge quoi et je n'étais pas le
seul
on était tous ceux qui étaient dans ce
voyage les journalistes et où on avait
le même sentiment
ce qui me rapproche aussi de bandas
c'est peut-être son combat quand il
parle des enfants donc voilà je le
comprends parce que moi j'ai vu ses
enfants j'ai été j'ai vu ses enfants se
jeter sur moi à table quand je mangeais
pour pouvoir rouler j'ai vu c'est en
enfant dans l'île autour des restaurants
et je ne comprenais pas comment pays
riches ou et à voir autant d'enfants
dans les rues et que ses enfants soient
abandonnés et qu' il
autant de problèmes de nourriture et
enfin bon je vraiment s'y défend ces
enfants là pour moi c'est quelqu'un de
très proche
oui
la suppression d'un grave différend
entre ces deux organisations sur glace
heures d'avis internement ils veulent
que je tombe à pic car que serait bon
aussi se passe chez marc noté musi mais
je te lever mountain 10 min
mais je me connais je tente de cordes
quantique mais je pense nous prouve
l'intérêt du malade est probant d'une
pauvre pour que coin de popstars son
frère camp du pauvre d'amour et de
formes mon pays dit que conques et
divers
une
on va
m
le jeune
nos amis
quand l'histoire d'être engagée au nom
politiquement je trouve qu'ils tout
artiste tout chanteur qui peut être
engagée soit pas engagé je pense qu'il a
la musique ou la peinture ça fait partie
de ces choses là même qu'on voyait non
mais c'est ça un contexte politique
parce que ce sont les intellectuels
artistes qui évoluent sur le monde
qui voyez
mais le nano
on me dit mais quel est ton engagement
dumas vidéo je suis engagé dans le dos
du sol de lévis face à ce bonheur joie
avec hbo saxo et c'est déjà la
management nous mais il y en a deux qui
peut faire de mille façons qu'on fait là
et puis être engagés politiquement
moi j'essaie de séparer les deux ne
marche pas naïf un bon mais j'essaye de
me dire que un artiste c'est forcément
aux déçus des partis quoi un artiste y
étaient et ils jouent pour tout le monde
ne joue pas pour 50% ou d'en voler ou 7
1% de sa monnaie et joue pour
logiquement nucléaire
marina d'amico
la conscience de l'artiste met en cause
chaque fois comme d'affaires une
composition artistique aux jeux c'est
pas comme tant d'autres ont fait faire
des liens bob dylan cheikh mc donald's
et fadli boukaka du congo allait bien
d'autres et ça c'est ma voix moi il faut
que ça continue
faut pas oublier une musique qu'on
retrouve six cesaria evora le sait pas
mais la retrouve
parce que bon les onces et cesaria evora
peut-être ou des cap verdiens vient
aussi donc voilà les dérobades cette
côte donc de l'afrique de l'ouest et
elle elle a réussi alors qu'elles sont
plus ou moins quelque chose de proche de
bongha puisqu'elle a pris même des
titres comme un garant du sénat comme
ceux d'adp pour la com elle les a repris
elle a fait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire donc c'est ainsi une
jolie histoire et elle a vendu sa à tout
le monde
camille moulage soldats de la base
étaient atteintes titres de musique
traditionnelle effectivement qui a été
chanté par bong iia sur l'enregistrement
de 1976 pourquoi justement moi j'avais
fait chanter son dada c'est arrière
parce que cela dans l'album de condat
c'était truc phénoménal
donc comme je considère que ces arias a
le même genre de nostalgie dans la voix
kabanga donc c'est de la personne aussi
idéal pour chanter cette chanson là mais
c'est vrai que les deux plus belles
interprétations de cela je pense que
c'est un gars qui bosse bien placé
add on qui nombreux ces années elle
arrivait pour les spots a besoin à
chaque fois qu'un artiste touche un
budget qui correspond à un besoin de moi
maintenant les hôtes c'est pas parce
qu'ils sont mauvais c'est parce que pour
l'instant c'est comme un accident d'être
au mauvais endroit au mauvais moment
un acte i c'est pareil être bon moment
au bon endroit a besoin de catéchistes
la voix de cette femme
tout est fait ailleurs pour que ces
années ne soient pas vedette
elle ne peut pas dire que c'est un canon
ben badi le propose par contre elle en
beauté mieux qui intéresse les gens et
ça dans le monde entier
saute à dos
tonga est quand même plus
professionnelle que c'est vrai c'est un
artiste qui est passé par il connaît
tout le showbiz il connaît tous les
rouages
c'est un monstre sème ses daria c'est
moi je dis toujours c'est pas une
artiste c'est une chanteuse qui a une
voix et sans air mais qui n'a pas
artiste du tout c'est un serial ne sait
pas ne sait rien faire pour play alors
que manga il a appris comment
attaquer le public d'un gars c'est
entrer et sortir dans le milieu du
showbiz
donc c'est totalement autre chose ils
étaient là avant il a préparé
inconsciemment directement et
indirectement le terrain aucune cesaria
evora vingt ans après éclate existe un
public qui dépasse le public africain
largement
sada je pense qu'un bon gars là n'a pas
eu de chance en france faire que il est
tombé à un moment où il la voix la
musique n'était pas encore inventé je
dirai où les magasins n'était pas prêt
pour accueillir tout le milieu
commercial n'était pas prêt pour
accueillir ce genre de musique
et surtout ce qui est important c'est
que des bons gars vingt ans après une
césarienne avouera banalise rendent
normal rendre rendre à limiter faisons
du pays' partie du paysage musical ces
musiques venues d'ailleurs
ça tient pourtant à dire qu'on un jour
ça vient de l'angola du cap vert ou
poitou charentes de l'ordre et tous les
jeux ne sont pas ne font pas trop des
arches entre les ces musiques là ce qui
n'est pas ce qui les touchera peut-être
si la série motion si c'est bien fait ce
côté artistique et c'est ça le gros
progrès dans lequel on peut dire qu'un
bon gars et plus tard ici ça rien autre
ont contribué
c
on m a jamais
on
china
c'est une richesse que toi tu sois
l'ouzo forme que ce soit francophone que
ce le soit anglophone et loutres espèces
pas nous machete est une richesse pour
nous on a quatre langues notre vision
qu'on met ensemble pour le destin commun
du continent africain
au fond
m
moi je veux amener la musique africaine
sur toulouse au fun vous aura eu du
monde entier c'est pas facile parce que
il ya du monde
les distributeurs au niveau mondial
beaucoup sont des vendeurs de plastique
donc il voit il faut de temps en temps
être très diplomate pour un peu ouvrir
la porte de ces gens là arrivé à leur
faire comprendre ce qu'il ya dans cette
musique là donc c'est pas facile c'est
pas facile c'est un énorme proba mais je
pense qu'on gagne du terrain tous les
jours
elana
j'ai gardé mon âme annie mac à l'ipad
allait mais il aimait aux lèvres
comme a dit un jour pierre torreilles de
le coran il a dit tout le monde s'est
moqué de lui à l'époque je rappelle une
phrase qu'il avait eue qu'on avait
besoin d'un interview d'un interview
pour une radio
il avait dit dans 20 ans on il n'y aura
plus que les musiques traditionnelles
qui avait fait rire tout le monde
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas que les
musiques traditionnelles mais ça a pris
une part de marché
absolument énorme tout ce que je
souhaite c'est que ça continue
rien que ça
et pour bon gars maintenant je pense
qu'il faudrait qu'il continue ça
caillait la façon laquelle il veut bien
si c'est lui qui décide mais il est
toujours là peut collaborer avec lui les
côtes est musical
donc on n'a pas encore le succès qu'il
mérite bon gars c'est un monstre qui a
une voix incroyable
tout le monde s'accorde pour dire je ne
suis pas dans l'historique comment il a
travaillé avant mais ce que je suis sûr
c'est que cette personne n'est pas
simple à ce malaise à dongo bataille
wilaya où l'allemand fait quelque chose
à quoi donc way to descendeur poulain
oui il faut le donner beaucoup plus
d'ampleur à cette guitare la flûte les
bonnes mais bon je vais me battre contre
je veux dire tout le showbiz mais aussi
contre l'artiste pour lui de faire
comprendre que dans le monde entier il
ya un public maintenant qui est ouvert à
cette musique là et qu'il faut peut-être
donner un peu plus de temps la
production réfléchir bien bien à ce
qu'on fait au titre tout ça donc pour
lui c'est une nouvelle démarche avant il
faisait un album en trois mois là je lui
parle de faire un album tranquillement
36 mois après l'annoncé par m
quand il sera prêt il sortir
des colons
tous
à
là
oh
à
tous
mais non